se encuentra en el aeropuerto del dorado
de Bogotá Colombia verdad cuéntenos Cuál
ha sido su experiencia qué viaje tenía
planeado hacer y qué ocurrió
una experiencia muy traumática así
confirmada estoy en el aeropuerto en
Bogotá El Dorado en Colombia estábamos
en Medellín en donde estuvimos 24 horas
la deriva como fantasmas dentro del
aeropuerto Porque nadie nos atendía no
no les importamos a nadie bueno Avianca
tomó cartas en el asunto pudimos viajar
a Bogotá ayer desde Medellín y por
supuesto sin comida
contemplados pero bueno ya pasó un
segundo plano eso y por nuestra cuenta y
ahora el vuelo Bogotá - Buenos Aires es
en breve en una dos tres horas no está
solo José María no está acompañado de
personas de su familia
digamos a sus niños
bueno imagino que esto hace más crítica
de la situación aún no una cosa es estar
solo otra es tener a cargo criaturas
sí tuvimos estuvieron durmiendo en el
suelo hasta que se me ocurrió abrir las
valijas e improvisar un colchón Así que
durmieron por sobre las valijas abiertas
y con mucho frío encima
cuéntenos Cuál es el clima que se vive
en aeropuerto me imagino que ha podido
dialogar con otros pasajeros en su misma
situación
sí éramos bastantes argentinos porque el
original era Miami Buenos Aires la
realidad es que la compañía quebró con
nosotros en el aire con nosotros volando
no sé por qué nos dejaron embarcar
porque una quiebra no se decide en un
segundo al otro no está planificado nos
dejaron embarcar y no les importó nada
dejarnos a la deriva en un país que no
era de nuestra elección
nos comentaba recién que la solución
vino por parte de Avianca cuéntenos
concretamente cómo será este mecanismo
para que pueda regresar usted a
Argentina
en principio llamó después de 24 horas
de estar ahí como comenté a la deriva en
el aeropuerto llamaron a formar una fila
afortunadamente fue el primero de la
fila por los dos menores no los
pasajeros a todos me conocían Así que sí
pasado pasá y empezaron a cenar aviones
como podían no tomé el que salía
inmediatamente acá para Bogotá porque el
plan era tomar ahora Bogotá buenos